let's talk about your your Netflix show
you're hosting this show and it's an
amateur baking competition I love this
idea it's called nailed it yes we're
people who shouldn't be give a quick
summary it's a really funny idea so
nailed it is where we take home bakers
and they compete win $10,000 by
recreating very extravagant things like
found on Pinterest or whatever and it's
very silly kids love it people love it
these are people that a lot of times
can't come close accomplishing but they
never come never it's funny because I
love like the British baking show I love
that show am i watch it with my wife and
kids but it was time there's so many of
those shows and people doing amazing
things I love that this is a show where
no one City good no one's good we're
really just putting mediocrity on a
pedestal yeah well we started that all
right here we see
so anyway we have some be sir free oh
you gave people this cake to make that
was a very good cake that represents
Donald Trump and then you ask them to
recreate it so here's the first attempt
that's an adult made that uh-huh grown
adult male took two hours of his life to
create that okay okay that's the next
one here we have another one oh my god
okay kind of in the same ballpark let's
look at the last one and oh my
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that was a guy from saw
man I love it when you're on the show
please come by like twice a week I love
it when you're in the program season two
of nailed it is now streaming on Netflix
I love her Nicole Byer we'll be right
back Dawes is here
you